sur ce petit lopin de terre aride perdu
dans l'atlantique
l'eau douce vaut de l'or
[Musique]
est ce que vous connaissez beaucoup de
terrains de golf sans pelouse comme le
nôtre l'île de sao vicente a beau être
entourée d'eau elle en manque
toute la vie s'est mise au régime sec
douche savon douche même dans les hôtels
de luxe
on demande à nos clients de préserver
l'eau les capverdiens utilisent des
baignoires mais je n'ai jamais entendu
dire qu'il prenait des bains dans leur
baignoire jamais au cap-vert avoir une
piscine c'est le grand luxe
dis-moi comment tu dépenses ton et je te
dirai qui tu es une mère au foyer comme
ça au fait tu l'as mis du mauvais côté
ou un laveur de voiture comme fred sonne
si tu économises de l'eau tu as du
travail et tu gagne plus d'argent
sao et fred sonne capable de tous les
efforts de toutes les astuces pour
quelques litres de plus
[Musique]
bon
dans le village de salam ansa le soleil
peut bien se lever
ce n'est pas lui qu'on attend pour
commencer la journée
non
celle qu'on attend c'est elle alice et
virginia la gardienne de l'eau
ça au fait la queue depuis une heure
déjà
[Musique]
moi tant que je ne suis pas venu
chercher de l'eau je ne peux pas
commencer à travailler
oh la la il ya tant de bidons déjà ça
lui gérald c'est elle qui tient le
robinet
[Musique]
sa physique tous et à tous les ragots
comme on dit j'aime bien venir chercher
de l'eau à la fontaine
je trouve mes copines ici ma marraine
comme toujours certains papote et
d'autres resquille avec ça ça fait trois
bidons tu prends à la légine âge ça fait
trois mois mais je t'ai dit que je
reviendrais on fera les comptes
c'est acquis le bidon jaune là dans ce
genre de choses il ya toujours des gens
rusé
rusé les tricheurs tu veux dire ils
peuvent toujours essayer de m'arnaquer
je suis plus maligne que parfois ils
remplissent des bidons et ils disent à
alice qui n'en ont pris que 5 mai ali
garde l'oeil sur l'eau
[Musique]
à cette fontaine l'eau n'est pas potable
en bilan est aimée l'officier s'il te
plaît c'est 50 centimes le bidon c'est
mon travail je dois respecter l'eau moi
je suis énervé quand je vois quelqu'un
gaspiller de l'eau je dois protéger
longue pause l'eau ce n'est pas quelque
chose qu'on doit gaspillé à tort et à
travers
c'est quelque chose de très important
j'ai les mois sur la tête
si t'as pas de force ou quoi c'était
faut qu'il soit bien centrer s'il est
trop en arrière je vais me faire mal au
cou s'il est trop en avant il peut
tomber pour l'équipe donc je le place
bien au milieu
sawa de la chance elle n'habite pas loin
de la fontaine avec ce premier bidons de
25 litres sa vraie journée de travail
peut commencer par exemple pour laver
cette couverture j'utilise presque deux
bidons d'eau mais si j'ai beaucoup de
linge à laver
celui de ma grand-mère de maisons clou
le mien jetée où j'arrive à dépenser 4
me dont je pensais que c'était seulement
au cap vert où on pouvait manquer d'eau
mais maintenant je voulais que c'est le
monde entier qui est touché j'aimerais
que tout le monde que même mon fils
fasse attention alors qu'ils
réfléchissent plus à cette question dès
la famille de sao consomme 8 millions
par jour huit bidons
seize voyages des milliers de partout
ouf
lafontaine est le vrai centre du village
à ça la main ça face à l'atlantique on
ne perd pas une goutte d'eau en ville
aussi on connaît le prix de l'eau
[Musique]
et il n'y a pas plus débrouillards que
les laveurs de voitures une tribu de
gavroche
[Musique]
près de sun casquette rouge
à 27 ans
avec ses amis ils ont l'eau gratuite
mais rationner la mairie leur envoie un
camion-citerne deux fois par semaine
lorsque le camion arrive tout le monde
ici est très content pour ce lot est
arrivé la citerne sera rempli il ne
manque que les voitures pour qu on se
mette à bosser mille litres à se
partager jusqu'à la prochaine livraison
fractionner ses amis doivent être sobre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on arrive à nettoyer deux à trois
voitures avec un seul saut d'eau surtout
quand le moment il faut éviter d'en
mettre trop sur la voiture il faut
utiliser la mousse
ça c'est le plus important si c'est
comme ça qu'on arrive à économiser l'eau
c'est parfois je me fais voler mon dos
quand je fais pas gaffe certains marnac
ils prennent montceau pour emplir le
leur en cachette et là c'est la guerre
laveur de voiture il est top cool mec ça
déchire
[Musique]
on est par ici quand une voiture
s'approche je me lève et je me lance
alors patron la lave a porté la ici je
vous la fais briller
ça marche comme ça je suis un sourire je
souris pour leur montrer ma motivation
ok car hélas ici gardez vous ici
pour moi il n'y a pas de souci il s'est
lancé en premier je suis là patron et
ceux qui ont loupé le coche se rabattent
sur d'autres clients
[Musique]
on
c'est important un vélo propres situé
invite une fille et que ton vélo est
propre elle voudra bien faire un tour
et pour ceux qui n'ont même pas de vélo
à se mettre sous le chiffon si quelqu'un
à bord de sa casquette à laver lave des
vélos des motos parfois des gens
m'appellent même pour laver leur canapé
concurrents mais quand même solidaires
faut pas pousser à nous la les gavroches
du lavage n'oublie jamais qu'il partage
le haut
[Musique]
on
dans le petit village de salamanca sao a
terminé ses allers retours ces deux
derniers bidon vont au potager
[Musique]
cette année tout le monde avait l'espoir
qu'il pleuvrait mais il n'a pas plu on
attendra l'année prochaine si je le
faisais des choses et c'est le seul
potager du village une folie dans un
paysage aussi aride
chaque année il coûte plus qu'il ne
rapporte
mais c'est aussi le souvenir que ça au
cultive ce potager c'est pour mon grand
père nous recommande à 100 c'est lui qui
l'avait créé donc c'est comme un
souvenir tant que le potager là mon
grand père reste avec nous dans nos
pensées
c'est sûr qu'il n'est pas grand et qu'on
perd même de l'argent avec et pour moi
ça vaut quand même le coup de le garder
la paix mais les boues
aujourd'hui c'est dimanche lafontaine
est fermé
sans eau et sa famille rendent visite à
un proche à l'intérieur des terres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
préval il est chauve c'est manathan
piolenc clip nos coachs
4 h gym acheteurs ces pauvres petites
billes à travail
pagano michel et un sourire tout à mes
genoux et c'est monté à bord
jeanne h il y a quelques années ces
endroits étaient tous vers vraiment vert
mais l'année dernière il n'est pas tombé
une seule goutte de pluie donc tout est
sec et très sceptique driessche
il y a quand même quelques taches vertes
dans le décor
comme cette oasis c'est ici que vit
l'oncle de sao
l'eau vient du sous sol
et quand on ouvre les vannes le
réservoir devient le temps d'un
après-midi une piscine éphémère au coeur
d'un jardin extraordinaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me sens heureux mais je ne peux pas
m'empêcher d'imaginer avoir toute cette
eau chez moi à voir à la maison beaucoup
d'eau comme ici
il n'y a pas de mots pour définir la
nature fait par dieu cette hausse est
une oeuvre de dieu pour moi c'est comme
ça
[Applaudissements]
longtemps
ainsi va la vie au cap vert le pays qui
n'avaient pas d'eau mais qui avait des
idées
[Musique]